[Music]
this next one is
called the microwave mind controller
i'm going to say that is a comic book
that is real and you actually refer to
it but it wasn't in cuba it was in the
soviet embassy
and they called it a microwave mind
controller
yes because it made people go [ __ ]
crazy like the
people would be unable to think for
themselves and
start stumbling around and it
permanently caused hearing loss and
they just were like hey there's
americans in that embassy and even
though we have an agreement with them
and it's supposedly
supposedly supposedly uh american ground
let's [ __ ] fire microwaves at them
until they go nuts
i mean that's like that is that's some
inhuman [ __ ] right there that isn't here
because like you're cooking a
[ __ ] on the inside right like
that's not like
you punch them in the head and maybe
they can come back from it like you're
frying parts of their brain
i don't think you cook them i think that
the frequency is such that it just
causes their thoughts to be scrambled
and they think that the reason that they
develop this weapon was that
originally they had been beaming
microwaves at the us embassy
of a different frequency because they
can use it as a surveillance device
they can pick up vibrations and this is
back in the day this is back when the
embassy used ibm's electric typewriters
and so they could hear the people typing
and they could record it at very high
speed slow it down
and that's electric type remember this
electric had that ball in it
and that's how you typed well unlike
another typewriter that has those little
arms that go
this thing it took a different amount of
time
very slightly different amount of time
for every letter
so they could listen to a slowed down
tape and actually transcribe what was
being typed
in that building oh that's very but but
even well not even scary but equally as
scary andy
is that's the best name they can come up
with for that
it's a little on the nose it is what
else you got
heart attack gun shoot somebody with it
and within
less than a second they have a heart
attack
my god is that what happened um that's
got to be fake
no that's real there's a heart attack
gun yeah after watergate senator frank
church investigated the cia
and found that they had created a
modified pistol that was capable of
delivering a nearly undetectable
but lethal dose of shellfish toxin into
the body of a distant target
the darts fired by the soundless gun
would leave a pin prick no larger than a
mosquito bite
dissolve instantly into the tissues and
deliver a payload so poisonous the
target would be almost guaranteed to
have a
heart attack within moments do they use
it did they say
uh they don't say if they used it and
who would know
they were like he died of a mosquito
bite that gave him a heart attack
like i i think that it was pretty
undetectable if they did use it
this is like uh that scene in um gross
point blank where [ __ ]
black's trying to like kill somebody
with like drop a poison in their mouth
like through the [ __ ] oh my god
that's crimson what else you got
okay this next one is now arrows are
very good for a silent uh murder weapons
but what if you want to be able to hurt
someone with an arrow
but not kill them this so this one has a
boxing rectal rectal arrow
boxing glove arrow that is green or
green arrow technology that's that is
you're absolutely right and probably the
dumbest comic book uh
what would just that curiosity you're a
smart individual if you could
somehow you know balance
the the [ __ ] glide potential of a
arrow with a boxing glove attached to
the front of it
which would be very front heavy and
probably go straight down to the ground
but
what what do you think the impact to the
face would feel like would it feel like
you were getting punched or worse
or would the arrow behind the glove like
the glove
stop but the arrow keep traveling the
shaft through the glove
i don't think you put into the pointed
arrow inside the glove but even
even if you don't it's still on a shaft
okay
so once the glove stops the shaft could
keep going and the shower the shaft is
an arrow in and of itself
it doesn't have an arrow head but
something traveling at [ __ ] 200 miles
per hour and then
your face stops the glove part which is
just a boxing glove
and then the shaft keeps traveling i
should have done that [ __ ] and [ __ ]
green arrow i don't want a [ __ ]
eisner award right now people be like
that's some crimson dark [ __ ] that's
some alan moore [ __ ] right there
okay flying aircraft carrier so this oh
that is from shield
okay now we're getting to a murky area
because
it also was from
uh world war after world war one no was
that it was world war one
did they actually have a helicarrier two
zeppelin-style airships were constructed
the uss
akron and the uss macon
both of which carried a crew of 60 men
that were capable of deploying and
recovering sparrow hawk
fighter planes in flight it was the
gremlins program
oh no there's and then they're trying to
bring it back now it didn't really work
they were a big move in target wasn't
great but now the gremlins program
is an audacious darpa initiative
that would uh take modified c-130 air
transports
and loaded with stealthy drones and
become
they would be able to take off and land
on the c-130s
so yeah that's a real life thing it's
irl i'm sorry i forgot to say that
because
it's as we know irl means in real life
i'm being shamed it's cb first and irl
um
what is the uh wow man i think it's
pre-cb
went because it was world war one you uh
it never occurred to me
that the helicarrier in
you know the marvel movies is an
incredibly stupid idea because it
is a gigantic massive target yeah and
they have some sort of mysterious
shielding and stuff there people can't
see it
i just thought it was when i heard of it
just start firing into the sky
i just thought it was like a carrier
that was big and people like that [ __ ]
is
one hell carrier that's a hella carrying
stop trying to be young
just say it's big and move on it's big
yeah that's what i thought hipster
[ __ ] doofus
leave the young to the youth to the
young stop pretending it's [ __ ] gross
got gray hair i'm like man
i don't know why i married her
all right this one yes is our last one
and it is called
the rod from god and it is
from outer space a rod with no it's
a metal rod gets thrown at a target at
the earth but because it
goes from such a high altitude it hits
the ground with the impact
of a nuclear bomb uh
cb or irl irl somebody's thinking and
doing that
yes they are and it's called project
thor which i like to kind of end this on
because that's the name of a comic book
character
i'm interested again i was about to tune
out being like what number is this but
you say thor and i'm like
thor ragnarok which way love and thunder
all right well let's see if i can get
through this sentence without um
you stopping me on a particularly
interesting word never
it is called a kinetic energy penetrator
and it's
due to not [ __ ] touch that one but
it's uh it's two satellites
one is the targeting satellite and the
and the other is
has all of these heavy um tungsten rods
that can be aimed using the aiming
satellite and once they're released
they can they can accurately hit they
haven't made it yet because it's very
expensive to bring that something that
heavy into space
but when it hits its target it goes off
like a nuclear bomb it just
it has so much energy in it from falling
from that height
but then and devastates it has all the
effects of a small nuclear device
but there's no radiation so they're like
it would be
devastating and ecological
so the idea is get rid of nuclear
weapons just throw
giant [ __ ] rods at the earth but i
mean it is like
they do have a weapon called the moab
which is the mother of all bombs
and that is basically a sewage pipe
some sometimes they can use it with
explosives in it and they sometimes they
do not
and they drop it from a bomber from a
high altitude so high in fact
that it can just penetrate through the
earth very deep and that's
also known as a bunker buster so the
idea is in use but on a
on a smaller scale um
what a terrifying way to end this it
sounded so promising with the
mention of thor but then became sobering
and real
when people were like look i still want
to kill a lot of people
but i don't want to hurt the environment
that thing is a freaking kinetic energy
penetrator
and he that thing flies back to him he
can use it over and over again
i tell you the best kinetic energy
penetrator is that iron man glove
you put that [ __ ] on
see how i circled back to the penetrator
word just to make sure we got something
in on it
i know you did you milked it for what it
was worth is that the second
section of the show that is that we're
done with that that is over
exited the five ladies and gentlemen
that means we're heading into the why
why why now as we know
in other podcasts people will write in
with their questions
and they ask experts for their answers
but in this case people write in and
they want kevin to answer
um that's me that's right
not a real expert well
um these are things where kevin gets to
ponder ideas
occasionally rather than give us
specific answers
what does kevin think of this so in the
first one stu the
and the nj bat dad also known as stu
greenberg writes in
considering grogu in the mandalorian
made me think
is baby talk universal or specific to
each language
and there is a right answer to this but
i want to hear what you have to say
is baby dog universal meaning is
whatever grogu
saying understandable to another baby
well that is part of the question that i
find the most interesting part
because babies don't tend to understand
each other right
is that what the question is positive i
think he's more saying like
do babies babble the same everywhere or
do they babble differently from country
to country
well i mean don't they babble in their
own language or they're like you know
blah blah blah blah blah
the same way that dogs here they say
dada and in britain they say
father father
um don't like dogs you know kind of like
barks with accents yeah sound different
in other countries and [ __ ] as do cats
cats meow in different languages dogs in
england are like
hoof dogs here are like woof there it's
like
woof and in the south of the united
states it's
[Music]
um i say yes
babies babies are good that was the
question
i support babies babies are good okay
all right our old friend shawn buss he's
coming up with some
you know get on the chambers
sean writes in um is there really a
mechanism in our bodies
that acts like a thermometer when the
weather is changing like
a storm is coming i can feel it in my
knee
is that it yes i've heard of that um
there is some sort of like you know
internal reaction to weather
um particularly as you get older from
what i've understood
is that correct andy well it's a this is
a controversial subject which is why i
wanted to bring it up because some
people think that there's absolutely no
truth to it that you're intuiting from
other things in the environment that
it's coming and those aches are
psychosomatic but there's also a lot of
people that believe that
say you have a like i have shoulder
injuries from swimming a lot when i was
younger
and so i feel like i can feel when the
weather's changing and it's going to
rain
and the people that support that theory
the scientists say it's because
in our joints and other places that ache
we have
little not joint those kind of joints
we have there's air there's air in our
joints and so that's why when you do
this
that's actually air popping in your
knuckles look at you man you look like a
little bruiser when you do
i should have given you some dialogue
where you're like maybe you want to pay
us that money now
no uh so yeah there it's there's two
schools of thought but
you know normally i'm the the 100
percent science guy and i got to go with
based on my shoulders but i got to go
with that yes there is a mechanism in
your body that does
allow you to feel changes in air
pressure barometric pressure
there's a mechanism in my body that's
going to allow me to kick that little
15 year old [ __ ] german dog right off
the deck man
right into the boiling oil that we're
gonna throw on the people as they come
up the hill
what did you call it what style it's a
citadel
citadel is that what they they do that
you know the presidio you know they just
uh castle castles they would always they
had what were called
uh readouts which were these little
places where you could pour oil out and
shoot arrows out
and then there was actually a place
where you can escape out and that is
called
a loophole get out of here yeah
that's where the hole comes from my
[ __ ]
kick checking right in her little
loophole jackie stop it
this is such hostility man she sees
another dog and she just gets so angry
she wants to be the only dog in the
world and then when she gets her wish
she's lonely yeah and then she's gonna
sit there and her glass she's gonna sit
on her glasses they're gonna be broke
and she's like
but i can't see that i'm the only dog he
wasn't british
hey man it's me kevin smith have you
been looking for all my old podcasts the
ones i started recording back in 2007
well guess what i found them they're all
hiding
in that kevin smith club see all the
video you've never seen including
exclusive movies and live
shows you want some swag that kevin
smith club is making pins
and miniature versions of my old scripts
do you want to be involved in the least
exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club
now's your chance to club kevin smith
okay one more question for you and this
comes from daryl reamers okay
i've heard from old daryl before he what
vegas is his twitter handle
and he says if i cut a magnet in half
what happens to the polarity will one
half be all north and the other all
south
a great question no they'll just go back
together
no say you separate them do you just
have an all-nighter
like years because like i've been
separated from people for a while and i
it's like when i see him against like i
haven't
i saw him just the other day it's like
no time has come down
you can't be extremely polarizing
so the question is can you cut the north
off of a magnet and have a north magnet
and the south magnet separately
my answer is no i refuse no not will you
to be friends would would that be
something that could happen
what would be the result break a magnet
is the question
no if you cut a magnet in half a
north-south polarized
magnet cut it in half is the north side
all just the north and the south side
all just the south oh i see
no because then the bottom of the south
the north becomes south
because everything's got a north and
south so you have to become like
listen i i know this is what you want to
hear america but you know you don't want
to hear america but you can't just
pick all north or all south
it all goes together you got to find a
way
to be magnetized together
magnetize together kevin is bringing us
together
with his magnet metaphor ohm spun wisdom
um i say the moment you break a magnet
there's always going to be a north on
the south side and you are correct sir
as
always i feel like sherlock holmes and
[ __ ]
really yeah like [ __ ] deducing that
where people like oh my god you're
brilliant and i'm like no it's just
elementary
the broken magnet indicates that it was
user reginald
who killed the then i start trying to
lay blame and
[ __ ] get people guilty of crimes like
it was a busted [ __ ] mag
yeah like why do you keep saying wayne
scouting
all right that does it that is it for
the for the uh why
we got the five show the second rule of
threes on the y
on this one the why you did it well done
uh shecky
i'm gonna [ __ ] rule you into three
little separate graves chop you up like
a little tuna
in three different cans and would he be
still polarized north and south that you
would
do it all over each section would have a
north and a south
um this is the y the by laser shecky
the bye ladies and gentlemen oh god
she's going we're gonna say
shecky get in here
you shut up
[Laughter]
we've been through this before you know
that she's barking to alert the family
and when you yell back
she's like i did the right thing now
everyone knows i'm like don't
do it god damn it what's she alerting us
to that there's another dog down there
just something good i'd take a look and
go you know what i prefer that dog
and then and then go pick up that nice
new dog that she alerted me to
she don't see the [ __ ] she just don't
see
you keep your mouth shut until you know
what the [ __ ] shot is you
goddamn little german dog
anyway what is the buy this weekend buy
that we just you know buy
to explain this to our new listeners uh
because by this point i think they're
the only one that could possibly be
listening this far into the episode
this is where we look at the science the
stories that happened in the last week
that are fun and interesting and that
kevin can
completely turn into something uh having
to do with abel
um now you know the b crisis that
bees are having massive bee die-offs
yes i can't even i can't even joke about
it man
like there's something going wrong with
the b b's getting out of this world
before we are man murder hornets
murdering them
yeah and then there's murder sherlock
holmes i mean sherlock holmes hornets
coming in and saying
it was you is a regional you did it um
it is it's a bad time to be a bee
all those times you were like [ __ ] man
bees got a good i wish i was a goddamn
now you're sitting there going like [ __ ]
[ __ ] being a bee
there but for the grace of god go
buzz eye so no here's the thing i don't
want to be a bee no more
there's a lot of a lot of uh
universities
and research groups are trying to study
the movements of these bees in this in
this phase to try to figure out what's
going on here but a statement the b
statement was
oh honey oh wow
oh beehive oh that's even better
so what are they finding out well these
are going on
you got to break it down you got to
break it down into what are we going to
spend our money on
and it turns out those little trackers
these like microscopic trackers that
they glue to the back of bees
they mostly work on bluetooth and they
only work for about
a few you know 20 feet before they they
lose them
and so they have to go where they think
they are and see if they can find them
with these trackers
so these guys a group in england uh
in the uk have they were like we've got
no idea
they didn't start killing all the bees
they said it like that
but they said we've got an idea we do we
do
we can no idea we do we do
we'll save the bees it's up to us
up to us to save a little bit
fuzzy nail p people like your
you don't have to compose a song for it
if you're gonna
you're gonna find something just please
be scientific about it we don't need a
song
based on being in the car at night and
coming upon
a construction scene the construction
site
you can see the vests those reflective
vests that the
construction workers are wearing well
before you ever see anything else on the
scene and so they made
teeny tiny b-size orange reflective
vests
and they put them on these bees and they
put them on the bees and they can see
them
from like 40 yards away and they can
track them and they can be like
they can go in and if wherever the bees
are they can shine lights everywhere and
they're like
there they are because they're wearing
those cute little vests
do they not they can't take them all i
don't think they
i don't know if they can take them i
don't know if that's even important i
think the bees are probably pretty happy
with these vests on
wires because they also have little slow
and stop signs that when they turn them
around it says that they can wave other
bees through
i can get another job aside hustle
when honey season is out i can be
working traffic
i love your drone voice
there's an upside to this this is
opening up new revenue streams for me
in this gig economy i'm a gig economy
honey
[Laughter]
um so that is kind of a neat thing and
the reason i bring it up is that i
always admire you know people go in and
try to find
the highest tech answer to problems now
they always feel like it has to be
coded and there has to be a microchip
and these guys figured out a low tech
solution that works better than any
technology we have so
hooray for them [ __ ] yeah
now here's another b uh b
uh story that is kind of a thing about
bees and murder hornets
i don't want to be story i want all a
stories well the b story can be very
important
and make you cry so this one is
a wellesley college research team
discovered that in order to repel
murder hornet attacks on their hives
southeast asian bees will go out and
gather animal feces and smear it all
over the hive entrance
and then the murder horn like grows
and they then they don't uh go in and
kill all the bees in there
is that right they're just like they're
turned off by a little poo could you
imagine your name is like you got
murder in your [ __ ] name but you're
like i'm gonna i'm not gonna kill
through pooh
yeah that this is they're taking this
[ __ ] to a whole new level
literally you can't get that smell off
i'm gonna [ __ ] who you are like no way
it ain't worth it is that corn yeah
somebody discard a papaya somewhere
because i'm not [ __ ]
i ain't [ __ ] with no bees that use
[ __ ] as a defense
that's just crazy uh evidently it really
wigs out the murder hornets they really
get upset by it and they
stay away but it's a very unusual move
for bees because normally bees
keep a very neat house they'll clean i
had i captured some bees here when
there was the bee crisis and i put a
beehive out and since gave it to someone
else but
what they do i was like reading all the
instructions they said don't clean it
that's how you'll know that they want
the hive is that they'll clean it out
so there's like little dirts and pebbles
or whatever things in there
and sure enough it came out one morning
and everything was on the ground in
front of it there was you could see that
they cleaned it out
and within three weeks they had moved in
it was pretty cool
they pick it up and they walk it out to
the front they chuck it over the side
i mean they're not they don't care about
their neighbors so much but they're very
neat anita's pin little little critters
and uh
in this case they're smearing [ __ ] and
sweet
which brings us to our why are they
sweet because of honesty make honey
yeah they also have a very important
point andy
in the end a very important point um
i get you're talking about their
stingers right yeah
very i it took me a second now
pandas they're discovering chinese
scientists
have confirmed anecdotal reports
that given the opportunity pandas will
smear horse dung
all over themselves there's a compound
in the poo
that keeps the pandas warmer in the
winter and so when it's winter time
they meticulously they'll find horse
[ __ ] from like
you know of course people riding horses
in the jungle or whatever wherever
they are in the woods and they just
start getting into it
and they spend hours meticulously
rubbing [ __ ]
all over their bodies and i'm like and
they don't mate
um wow so like all right so the bees
are picking up [ __ ] cause they're like
we gotta protect ourselves from the
murder hornets but the pandas are just
like i like it
they like to stay warm yeah but i just
imagine it's like
look mommy there's a there's a brown
bear
that's not brown bear it's a banner
you're kind of right
um wow man like the longer
we live and the longer um you know
scientists keep investigating the
wonders
of our world the more we find out weird
[ __ ] like that
like [ __ ] pandas love horseshit
do you think there's a marketing
opportunity where we can sell because
panda stuffed
doll stuffed bears are huge sellers it's
one of the most popular kind of stuffed
animals you can buy
do you think we should sell them just
covered in [ __ ] caked with dumb
absolutely i think somebody needs to get
in touch with
uh goop because there's like they can
you know make their own kind of poo
powder
a little lifestyle lifestyle guru choice
obviously they care obviously the pandas
are just like i'm applying it very
specifically yes if you look
you'll remember when we talked about
those lines
look again do you see them gone right
guys who am i who am i i'm mr ed's lunch
do you think that they could stand guard
uh beehives
like they're covered in [ __ ] they're
like relax fellas i got this
i know they could probably team up and
[ __ ] and pandas are like if you give me
a little honey
i'll watch your beehive like why are you
speaking with a british accent
it looks like [ __ ]
fecal freaks of nature i'm just a little
brown turd ball
hovering outside a honey tree
[Laughter]
all right well the last article i
thought you might enjoy okay
uh a yale professor in a recent book
which is now
getting a lot of coverage a lot of
people are believing in it
is saying that once the pandemic is
over yeah once everyone is inoculated
and
nobody's sick anymore comic-con is going
to be back i'm going to have a
sex-crazed
roaring 20s like you have never
never seen he's like sex
sacrilege and spending await society on
the other side of this coronavirus
people are just going to
it's going to be i agree i i mean i know
like of course people are um
[Music]
trying to make ends meet in this uh
bleak economy but there's a bunch of
people that have
surplus cash i'm not talking about rich
people and i'm talking about literally
cash like that normally go to comic book
shows and stuff like that
who are just been sitting on that cash
for like a year
and you know yes of course they're bang
wheels and stuff like that
but some people who are lucky enough to
continue working through all this
are just itching to [ __ ] spend i
could see that being the case man
okay i look forward to being able to
go to a show and like
buy some stuff again okay that is what
sex craze did you freeze sex crazed orgy
brings up to you is going and buying
comic books yeah
that's where you went that's my age
i'm 50. um yeah i would have
who's got the energy well i mean yeah i
mean
i've i've been quarantined with the
person that before after quarantine
that's the person i have sex with so
it's not like you know suddenly like hey
honey
now that the you know we're out of
coving should we just go have a [ __ ]
orgy like my sex life ain't gonna change
when i owed it
sounds like good news for a bunch of
people that aren't me though so good for
them you wouldn't you wouldn't even say
it like you wouldn't be like honey this
is a yale professor
dr nicholas this guy and dr nick wants
us to [ __ ] other people
hi everybody you ain't got to be a
weather man to know which way the
[ __ ] wind blows andy
and that's our political [ __ ] message
well bob dylan in the afternoon is that
he
was that he's the guy that said that it
doesn't mean no matter when weather
meant to know which way the wind blows
what is that
so homesick blues number two or
something
it's in the lyrics and the lyrics of a
bob dylan song you know
the pumps won't work because the vandals
took the handles is that the end of the
buy
that's the buy that's it my fine young
cannibal all right no more [ __ ]
content left to give you kids man there
was a sigh
there was a five there was a y and there
was a bye
and and uh and our flag was still
there jose
can that's not what are the words again
i just kind of hit a little it's very
there's a lot of there's a lot of
allergens in the air i have to apologize
for my glottal mistakes
we saw a [ __ ] uh time trap door where
[ __ ] young andy slipped in for a
second
replacement when it's time to change you
know i got too real
and he was in his uh [ __ ] junior high
swim team
yeah i was probably eight he had
flipping i've had a deep i've
had a mustache when i was eight and a
half did you really yeah
and i was like for breakfast you know
like give me a brandy
you're [ __ ] seven i said give me some
candy
all right sounded different the first
time
then you try with the next bartender a
couple hours later
you do that enough time sooner or later
you hit a bartender he's like he's a kid
a brandy i don't give a [ __ ]
this is his voice he doesn't have long
it's got a lot of confidence
uh do you like it folks did you like
getting edumacated you were scared going
into it but now you're [ __ ]
glad that you took the plunge now you're
like why have i waited
i should have been doing it all along i
should have been getting edumacated the
[ __ ] out of
oh my god now i want to get educated
from behind
welcome to the world of education
we don't do this show we don't learn
nothing
there is no education without
not a real professor yeah well i think
you've proven that over
this show i feel more like a minder like
i'm a sort of
doing the psych experiment on you or
something you're a mind scrambler what
was the
[ __ ] device called the mind
microwaver the microwave
mind control it's yeah
such a weird long name it's like calling
a gun like
a thing that has something in it that
explodes that comes out and then hits
something
the heavy metal propeller thrower
heavy metal just can we call it g-u-n
for sure like irl
[Laughter]
all right there it is kids you got
[ __ ] smarter for free
you didn't have to spend no money on
college you don't know sally may or
dickie mack or whatever [ __ ] those
[ __ ] are
you owned nobody you got smarter for the
time
not the dimes man cause you went to the
university of
ladies and gentlemen for edumacation i
am your host kevin smith
and i'm andy mcelfresh and you have just
been
[Music]
edumacated